[Music]
this is bear son it was the home of your
grandparents and their grandparents
before then but out there beyond the
edge of the world
why is the home of the Dragons
and I believe this your destiny to one
day find this hidden world
[Music]
you don't know my leg isn't a chew toy
don't you is this what you want yeah
okay
how am I supposed to get down hey buddy
wait up
he's not the only one
[Music]
another night three weeks is more like a
bright light theory
yeah yours is better probably there is
an armada with enough cages for all of
our dragon vein
this is a new kind of enemy we need to
find the hidden world I wouldn't destroy
everything you realize
even nothing without you a blender if
primo succeeds there won't be any
dragons left and it's up to us to put an
end to it so what are you gonna do about
it
suit up gang we have one shot you
brought a baby to a battle
the hidden morals have really touched
the key
right but inside
[Music]
not a word I know this handiwork
grimille the grizzly famous back where
I'm from
smartest dragon hunter I ever met Wow
next to me of course I can't be that
smart he left his trap on man
nothing's accidental when it comes to
old grimille he lives for the hunt to
get inside the mind of his prey to
control its every choice it's all a game
to him well he doesn't know who he's
playing with yeah well we've dealt with
his kind before
don't underestimate him hiccup not my
words it will be back then we'll be
waiting for him okay Chet its kid yeah I
need you to feel it it's cold it's gray
you're covered in pelts oh and you're
auditioning with some big Hollywood star
oh really
hey and accent hold brother's the Beast
can smell your fear dragon show yourself
sorry I didn't see that in the script
was this push to him not me oh hey is
your bit all you need to do is leap on
this mark when I say no no no no get
back I'll just explain the Q the Q is ah
okay be honest toothless do I come
across as too brooding hmm because
Arthur tongue I'm just trying to
remember where I left my keys brothers
no all of us will see daybreak but
dragon show yourself
toothless no no put it down down
lunch everybody Catering top-notch mate
I got you this salmon I'm a little
confused about my part really
I mean first I'm dead then I'm not no
one knows you're my mother isn't
brothers we have four strong we have
fought hard and we must continue to
fight until our foes are defeated
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
toothless would you mind if I am
[Music]
can we get them cleaned out please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm not a demon see just a guy just a
guy here to rescue these dragons so
dragons shed a loss oh I know what demon
wanna see what no human legs are not
standing legends tell of ships the sail
too close to it only to drop off the
edge of the world never to be seen again
but those sailors who turned back told
tales of a great waterfall and Dragons
guarding the entrance to a hidden world
not just the nest hiccup but a lion from
which all dragons come even make
theories especially night Furies those
are scary don't you buddy one day I'll
find the hidden waddled and seal it up
so that people and Dragons will fight no
more
DreamWorks presents How to Train Your
Dragon world first learn the legend out
there beyond the edge of the world lies
the home of the Dragon and I believe
this your destiny go find this
what are you gonna do about it shoot up
gang your team really touches hang on
tight discover a world of mystery and
Wonder
now back the king just don't get caught
this year
once you've seen that in the world
nothing will ever be the same again
[Music]
Sarge we got a situation someone took
the ball the ball how cute
toothless is not yours
hand it over I'm getting too old for
this shift we've got a developing story
in Boston let's head out there now some
of the biggest players bring their kids
so I brought a dragon figured it was
time to snip load my press conference
game DreamWorks How to Train Your Dragon
they hidden world still working on
training DreamWorks How to Train Your
Dragon the hidden world is almost here
and we're gonna get you caught up in no
time
it all started with Berk home of Vikings
sheep and Dragons
this is hiccup and our story really
begins when he catches the most powerful
dragon of all toothless and pretty so
they're best friends and convincing
hiccups dad and everyone else that
dragons and Vikings don't have to be
enemies thank you then all the pickup's
friends become true dragon riders like
Fishlegs it's not loud ruffnut and
tuffnut and astrid who becomes kind of a
thing with hiccup and just when we
thought we knew everything about
training dragons hiccups mom shows up
and changes everything again
and Drago and his alpha appear and kind
of ruin everything
but luckily toothless and hiccup find a
way to save the day
and that brings us up to right now it's
hidden dragon worth witness the epic
conclusion of the friendship of a
lifetime you're right button
it's time
[Music]
there were dragons when I was a boy
where they went
only a few know our story changed the
world forever we did it
the world's first dragon Viking utopia
Julia don't be on maybe Mike's lace
president more Oh Stan attorney advised
wait up
oh he's not the only one she's a light
fury oh sorry did he just disappear
Wow
it's a hidden dragon worth
toothless go introduce yourself has a
girlfriend I've hunted every Night Fury
except yours and him over I will never
give him up then I will destroy
everything you love
we are no longer safe here we all have
to disappear completely off the map we
have to fight for their freedom
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't nothing without your dragon
show them what you got
[Music]
if you and me bud Oh
[Music]
[Music]